hey guys it's max we just got in
microsoft's new
surface go 2 and today we're going to be
putting it against
apple's 10.2 inch ipad with
logitech's new keyboard case that
includes a trackpad
and seeing which one of these deserves
your money we're not only going to be
talking about things like
performance of the cpu and graphics the
displays
the cameras keyboards and trackpads
we're also going to be talking about
things like
battery life software support actual
real world performance and much more
now when you buy either one of these
devices they actually come
basically in just a tablet form so let
me go ahead
and take off all these extra accessories
and let's start out just talking about
the differences
holding these in the hand the ipad is a
little bit more comfortable because it
is
thinner but is actually slightly larger
than the surface go 2.
it's a little bit wider and slightly
taller even though it does have a 10.2
inch display
compared to this one's a 10.5 inch
display
the surface has a 3x2 aspect ratio
whereas the ipad has a 4x3
meaning that you actually get a little
bit more vertical space if you're using
them sideways
because of the aspect ratio but overall
the screen size is
fairly similar now the ipad does have
these
massive bezels on the sides or forehead
and chin if you're going to be holding
it vertically
it does feature apple's touch id so they
need space for that
whereas the surface is a lot more even
overall
surprisingly we don't have that big of a
difference in weight you can't really
tell in the hand
and one reason why the surface is
thicker is because it has a built-in
kickstand that is very well made the
ipad doesn't have one of these so if you
do want to set it up like this
be able to watch a movie or something
else you're gonna have to use that
keyboard case
whereas with the surface it's all built
in and it works really well
on the bottoms we have our proprietary
connectors for the keyboards
and then on the right hand side the ipad
just has a lightning port whereas a
surface has
a usb type-c port which is great and
microsoft's proprietary surface
connector
which you can use for charging with a
dedicated included 28 watt charger for
fast charging
and you can also plug in microsoft's
proprietary different accessories
both have headphone jacks which is great
the ipad has it on the other side
and then the surface has one extra bonus
connection
which i'm so glad about if we pop open
this little cover
we actually have a micro sd card slot so
you can expand the storage
really easily and cheaply which the ipad
doesn't offer
another really cool thing about the
surface is that we have dual stereo
front firing speakers
whereas the ipad just has the one mono
speaker
on the bottom and then if you're holding
it horizontally or if it's in the
keyboard case
it is facing the right hand side which
kind of sucks
let's go ahead and do a speaker test you
guys put on your best pair of headphones
[Music]
[Applause]
all right i did not expect that
i expected the ipad to get whooped in
this test
but that didn't happen did you guys tell
the difference there
the surface go 2 doesn't sound bad the
speaker quality is good
but it is so quiet i actually thought
there was something wrong
i triple checked the volumes i checked
the window settings
everything is turned up all the way the
ipad
you definitely can tell that the sound
is coming from this direction if you're
holding it like this if you're watching
a movie music video if you go
vertically which the video experience is
much worse
audio is more much more balanced between
both ears
but it is so much louder on average
probably about eight to nine decibels
louder that is a massive difference
both of these have dual cameras you have
a camera on the front
and a camera on the back the ones on the
back i don't recommend people taking
pictures with them
but they are both 8 megapixel and they
are useful for doing things like
scanning
documents so i'm gonna go ahead and take
a picture and you guys let me know which
one
looks better to you guys as far as the
image quality
now for the front facing cameras the
ipad has a 1.2
megapixel camera compared to 5 megapixel
on the surface
now let's go ahead and do a webcam and a
microphone test
this is the webcam and microphone
quality that you could expect with the
surface go
2 microsoft is using a 1080p webcam and
dual front-facing microphones that they
say are studio quality
and this is the video microphone quality
that you can expect from the 10.2 inch
ipad
it is a 720p webcam or front-facing
camera
and as you guys could tell it is cropped
in a lot more than the surface
and the other thing is if i'm not
directly staring at the camera which is
right here on the left hand side
it's also lower down if i look at the
screen it looks so awkward it looks like
you're not paying attention to
whoever you're talking to so if you're
trying to take notes and do say a zoom
call
it just looks really weird and it's also
a bottom angle
and now let's talk about the keyboards
and the trackpads
trackpads are brand new for ipad os
we're glad that apple added them
and apple has their magic keyboard for
the ipad pros but those are very
expensive and just for the high-end
laptops for the 10.2 inch ipad this is
logitech's keyboard case which we do
have a review on
and it looks surprisingly similar to
microsoft's which has been around
for a long time now this keyboard case
actually works surprisingly well
the keys themselves are actually
slightly larger than the ones
on the surface go they're slightly
larger
they feel pretty decent overall you
could definitely use it for
typing not a lot of complaints there we
do have extra function keys
on top and then towards the bottom we
have this track pad
and it also works surprisingly well with
no lag at all because we are using that
smart connector
it is a diving board design so it's
harder to click
up top microsoft's is also pretty much
the same design
very similar size it does feel a little
bit nicer when you're clicking
or you can also use tap to click on both
of them now both of the keyboard covers
can be easily detached
if you don't need them to get them out
of the way but microsoft's
is thinner and lighter which is nice and
the magnetic connection
is a little bit stronger as well so if i
had to choose one of these i would
definitely hand it to microsoft they've
been making these for a while
and even though i don't like that the
keycaps are smaller once you get used to
them it works just fine that's a little
bit better overall
the logitech case has a little loop at
the top where you can store
your apple pencil that you have to buy
separately whereas
the surface go it actually just attaches
magnetically
to be honest i don't really like having
this loop over here because if you're
not going to use the pencil
it's just always just right there but
the benefit is
you do have a much more secure fit
you're not going to lose your apple
pencil
compared to with the microsoft it is
much easier for this to get detached and
get lost
with the ipad obviously it doesn't have
the hinge built in like the surface
so you have to keep this case on it in
order to have access to this hinge
and that makes it thicker than the
surface but it does give some protection
and then the hinge itself is not as nice
it's a little bit more flimsy
it is not as sturdy as the one that's
built into the surface
and now we're going to compare the
screens but you guys might notice that i
have these guys plugged in now
and that is because the ipad died and
unlike the surface that has that fast
charger that can charge up
in about an hour the charger takes about
four
hours to fully charge so we're gonna
leave these guys
plugged in now as far as the resolutions
they are very similar
about 220 pixels per inch so both are
nice and sharp
but the ipad does have an advantage with
brightness its display is about 500 nits
compared to the surface which is roughly
350 to
and as far as reflectivity both are
about the same they are
fairly reflective so the extra
brightness of the ipad definitely comes
in handy
one benefit of the surface is that the
lcd display
is actually attached to the glass it's
laminated so there's no air gap
and that way when you're drawing or
writing you're seeing that
right on top of the glass it's much
nicer
whereas with the ipad there is a gap so
sometimes it looks like it's a little
bit off from the tip of your
apple pencil but the apple pencil
surprisingly
with the ipad is a lot more responsive
and there's less delay
or lag whereas with the surface pen
you can actually get quite a bit of
delay as you guys can see
right here now the surface pen does have
a few more features
it has a button up here a button at the
top and to charge it there's actually a
quadruple a it's a very slim battery
inside that you need to swap
out with the apple pencil you don't have
any buttons or anything like that it's
much more simple
and this has a built-in rechargeable
battery where you actually just plug it
right into the lightning port hopefully
it's safe and it'll really quickly
recharge overall
if you're into writing or drawing i
think you're gonna have a better
experience with the ipad
not only because there is less lag and
delay but also because there are
so many apps available on the app store
that are inexpensive
and really nice now it's time to talk
about performance and this is where it
gets a little bit tricky
before i go into some real world
performance differences and some
benchmarks i want to mention that
the surface go to comes with windows 10
s and that is a version that only allows
apps from microsoft store
and those apps are very very limited and
that's because they want to maximize
battery life they want to make sure it's
secure
and have it run faster but you're most
likely going to have to get out of that
if you want to be able to compete with
app selection
with ios so that's the first thing i'm
going to do is i'm going to get out of
windows s mode
because without that i can't even run
some of the apps i need for this video
luckily it is very easy you just hit
learn more and then hit
get and it's completely free to get a
full windows license
and there you go we are out of the s
mode
and they want to know why we got out
because we want to use the apps that we
need
and once you switch out you can't go
back in so we're running full windows 10
now
and now we can run our geekbench 5 test
let's get started right there and both
of these devices
actually have pretty old processors we
have the a10 fusion
in the ipad 10.2 inch it's an old
processor
and we have an intel pentium gold
old processor here as well uh very
not very fast we do have four gigs of
ram on the surface compared to 3 gigs on
the ipad
but ipad os is much more efficient and
can use that ram much better than
windows which is
heavier and it needs more resources as
you'll see in just a bit
and since the surface is running windows
we have to make sure that we change
the power settings to full performance
or best performance
typically it's set to balanced and i
just found that it is just
way too slow in that balanced mode and i
had to set it to best performance
for it to be usable interesting the ipad
finished first where the surface it's
only about 60
done we have our scores and wow
as far as single core the ipad is over
80 faster and in multi-core it's about
50 faster with the surface in the best
performance mode and it's plugged in as
well
and i thought this ipad was very very
slow
now that only tells part of the story
the ipad is
optimized to work as quickly i've been
using the surface go to
and it felt slow even when i put into
best performance mode
that helped but not enough for opening
apps and things like that slow and even
using the web browser felt kind of
sluggish
so uh right now i'm running browser
benches speedometer and that's gonna
give us the performance of the web
browser how fast things load how snappy
it is
and wow that explains it
we have you know 19.3 compared to 65
more than three times faster with the
ipad
and that's not even that impressive of a
score just to prove we are in the best
performance
mode how about we go ahead and
maximize our window
come on you could do it there you go
we're maximized minimize
get moving all right there you go and
just to prove that our internet speed is
fine
there we go we're at a hundred no issues
with internet speed
so that is very unfortunate
and with the surface go to you do have
an option to spend more money
and get an m3 processor and that
actually costs you an additional 230
dollars it also gives you
faster storage and more storage
basically double storage double the ram
and the faster processor but even then
you can look at the speeds of that
higher end m3 processor and it is
just slightly ahead of this ipad and
then you're looking at 630 dollars
compared to this ipad which is 330 and
sometimes you can buy as low as
250 will leave some links down in the
video description
for the best deals let me show you a
couple other real world examples let's
go ahead and
launch adobe lightroom and this is
actually the optimized
version that was in the windows store
that works with windows
s um if you had the non-optimized
version say lightroom classic
it would be much slower you guys saw
that this launched within a few seconds
on this old ipad new ipad but using a
very old processor
whereas this i mean how long did that
just take us 15
20 seconds or even more let's do a
couple of very simple adjustments i have
just my temperature here
on the ipad this is instant as as i'm
sliding
i see exactly what i'm adjusting to i
can fine tune
get the exact right setting and here
let's go ahead and adjust this
come on you guys can see
it adjusts every once in a while
and it's harder to dial in what you want
because as you're sliding
it's not keeping up unless you're going
to go incredibly incredibly slow
let's go ahead and undo that and let's
do a little bit of a pinch to zoom
you guys see it's lagging up here
all right and then check this out on the
ipad
perfectly smooth and keep in mind these
are both optimized for the systems
there's a massive difference in
performance and this is just a 12
megapixel
jpeg image it's not a 24 megapixel from
a
actual camera it's not a raw image that
you might want to edit those kind of
images would perform
way worse than the image that i have
opened here
and now let's go ahead and run geekbench
5's graphics test
and here we go we have 4 000 for the
surface go 2
and 2700 for the ipad so the ipad
actually loses here
but it once again it comes back to
optimizations lightroom does use
graphics and we saw the performance
difference there
and if you're somebody that's going to
want to play some games you definitely
want the ipad because
the app store has a ton of great games
low cost free games that are optimized
and now let's talk about
prices i have about six hundred dollars
invested right here in this surface
package
400 for the surface 100 for the keyboard
case with the cheaper materials
another 100 for the pen now with the
ipad
i have 500 invested here so the ipad is
actually 250 bucks
that's the best sales you can get or
originally it's 330.
keyboard case costs more it's 150 so
that makes it a 400
package 100 more for the apple pencil if
you
bought it for the regular price of 330
that brings it up a bit but still less
expensive
than the surface and that really brings
me to our final
verdict on which one should you buy
the ipad is great all around and if
you're somebody that is looking for
a tablet as number one and then you
might wanna add in the keyboard case if
you wanna do a lot of typing and then
the trackpad comes in handy
you're gonna have a great time you're
gonna have all the optimized apps but
you're still gonna have certain
downsides like the camera being
lower and on the left hand side whereas
the surface
is more of a windows computer that can
be used
as a tablet even though it is just sold
as a tablet
if you're somebody that knows that you
need some dedicated apps that will only
run
on windows and you're going to want to
use it for web conferencing say
with zoom you're going to be using the
keyboard more often in trackpad more
often
and then less often you'll detach it and
you'll use it as a tablet the surface is
going to be a better choice for you
it is much more of a laptop replacement
but i don't like the speakers and i
don't like how slow it is
and if you want it to be usable for all
around use
then you need to spend the extra money
and it gets a lot more
expensive because of that overall i
think for most people the ipad makes a
lot more
sense yes it does have its limitations
and downsides
but it has more upsides than that it
works excellent as a tablet you have
access to
a crazy amount of great apps that are
well optimized
let me know your guys's thoughts down in
the comments section below if you want
to see the full review after i've had a
little bit more time with this
click that circle above and if you guys
want to see a couple other great videos
we have them right over there and as
always we have links in the video
description this has been max and i will
see you in the next video